okay a media company called aussie media
that you probably haven't heard of uh
had their coo i kid you not impersonate
a youtube executive while trying to
close a 40 million dollar investment
from goldman sachs okay so to give you
background on ozzie
which you probably don't know about it
is a digital media company whatever that
means they produce a ton of newsletters
a ton of podcasts youtube shows uh and
in-person events virtual events and they
make the majority of their revenue
apparently from
paid partnerships which means
sponsorships which means advertising
that's not tracked basically when you
hear partnerships it means people are
one-off paying for something and maybe
they're not looking at the roi the
return on investment exactly like they
might on facebook or twitter when
they're buying ads they have licensed
programming deals with a bunch of
platforms hulu amazon history channel
pbs bbc youtube uh and supposedly they
make eight figures from aussie fest
a-o-z-y fest is according to axios which
is a two day live event
which is kind of like comedy plus
uh music plus discussion so they're kind
of taking like a little bit of ted a
little bit of coachella and a little bit
of like is it the aspen comedy festival
or telluride there's some comedy
festival people go to uh where you just
go see comedians back to back back i
don't know what that would be like to go
to a comedy festival and go to like ten
comedy shows in three or four days maybe
that'd be interesting i'm curious if
anybody's ever been to that so uh aussie
fest was postponed in 2019 at 2020 uh
and in 2021 ozzie is hosting uh three
virtual festivals it's a little side
note they were sued by ozzy osbourne's
ass fest back in 2017. i don't know if
uh ozzy won that but
when i first heard oz fest i thought it
was
ozzy osbourne's oz fest but uh spelled
slightly differently
they launched in 2013 quote as
a gen x dream of what millennial media
ought to be earnest policy focused
inclusive according to the new york
times article in other words my
generation people were born in the 70s
and 80s trying to
think about what millennials who were
born right before uh the year 2000 what
they would want in a media company uh
policy focused woke you get the idea
uh so in 2021 axios reported that aussie
media did 50 million in revenue in 2020
and was profitable some more numbers
that uh aussie gave axios revenue growth
of 50 year over year for four years in a
row
ozzie's five newsletters collectively
having more than 20 million subscribers
the new york times article compared this
claim to morning brew which said it had
three million subscribers yet seems to
have much more reach than us ozzy so
that's a little weird and according to
pitchbook ozzy has raised over 80
million since 2013 was last valued at
160 million in november of 2019 so
that's the background uh the co-founder
carlos watson is the ceo and also their
star talent watson has his own interview
show the carlos watson show i've never
seen it i've never heard about him
before ozzy media and i'm in the media
space so it's a little weird
and he helps co-host other podcasts and
shows on aussie
a quote from new york times article mr
watson often disavowed an interest in
turning the company into a vehicle for
his own broadcasting talent so he was
dealing with that
you know same issue oprah has when or
you know
martha stewart had where they become the
figureheads that's what grows the brand
but then you become a bit of a liability
all right so here's the story and this
is just bonkers in 2021 goldman sachs
was working on closing a 40 million
dollar investment in aussie media
according to the new york times
on february 2nd aussie executives
including watson had a zoom call booked
with members of goldman's investment
team and youtube's head of unscripted
programming alex piper piper was
included on the call as part of
goldman's diligence to verify ozzy's
claims about their traction on youtube
piper was apparently running late and
had trouble connecting to the zoom call
so he suggested they do an old-school
conference call over the phone at the
last minute hmm it's a little red flag
right because zoom works every time like
conference calls don't work that's why
we all went to zoom because zoom does
work in a stable so to go the ah has
anybody
ever said let's not do a zoom let's go
back to the old conference calling
system
that's never happened that's not a thing
super red flag for everybody at goldman
sachs clearly so once everyone switched
to the conference call piper allegedly
told the team from goldman quote
ozzie was a great success on youtube
racking up significant views in ad
dollars and that mr watson was as good a
leader as he seemed to be
so okay now we're going to take a crazy
turn quote from the new york times
article as he spoke however the man's
voice began to sound strange to the
goldman sachs team that's not what it
might have been digitally altered
what
after the meeting ended someone from
golden reached out to youtube's piper
via their assistant not via the gmail
address on the calendar invite hmm a
gmail address piper received the message
but was confused and told the investor
that he had never spoken to them before
and that's not something you want to
hear if you're goldman sachs obviously
when youtube learned that someone had
apparently impersonated one of their
executives at a business meeting its
security team started an investigation
obviously and here's the quote from the
new york times article within days mr
watson had apologized profusely to
goldman sachs saying the voice on the
call belonged to samir roa
the co-founder and chief operating
officer ozzie i hope i'm pronouncing
that name rayo or
roa rayo maybe r-a-m in an apology email
to massach's aussie's ceo carlos watson
quote said
he attributed the incident to a mental
health crisis and shared what he said
were the details of mr rao's diagnosis
samir rao took time off work after the
incident but is now back working at
aussie and the board never formally
investigated the matter hmm one more
crazy insight from the story ozzie was
running full page ads in the new york
times that were made to look like
magazine covers
which you can see here notice right
under me carlos watson this is quote
attributed to deadline the best
interviewer on tv
uh twitter user and vice correspondent
michael c moynihan
did some digging and found the quote in
a deadline article and the quote was
said by aussie ceo ceo samir rao
not anyone at deadline and samir is the
same guy who impersonated the u2
executive so let that sink in now we've
talked before about frauds um when you
are selling stock in a company and
you're lying
and you're doing it in not a not i mean
we're not talking about massaging the
numbers here we're talking about fraud
impersonating another person outright
lying this saying the person's the best
person uh interviewer on tv and it's
from deadline you know you could see
somebody weaseling their way saying oh
yeah no it's a mistake somebody in the
graphics department saw the quote they
didn't you know
they should have put it was from us we
shouldn't have used it but it was a
mistake you know no harm no foul but to
create a gmail address of a youtube
executive
and then use a voice modulator in a
pre-metadata fashion to get them off
zoom onto a conference call this is like
the premeditated murder you know like
there's a difference between like
somebody gets in a fight they punch
somebody in a bar fight and the person
dies it's like well i didn't i was drunk
i got in a bar fight i didn't intend to
kill them
versus the person who's like i went to
the hardware store i bought like ammonia
i bought plastic tarps and i see i'm a
serial killer and i killed this person
and then i buried them and you know like
not to get graphic here but i'm
premeditated you understand what that
means
so um obviously basically quoted
themselves but use the deadline as the
coverage crazy you know aussies private
company so numbers are hard to verify
this is what i do for a living as an
angel investor i
do diligence and right now
i think there is so much fraud going on
in the private company space and in
crypto
um that it's going to be a parade of
perp walks in the next three or four
years uh we already saw that with crypto
right all the crypto cases the icos all
the fraud we talked about in crypto five
years ago you're starting to see
bitconnect and all these other crazy
people get pinched
you know the the long arm of the law
takes a little time but when the hammer
comes down it comes down
uh and
this grift is just unlike any i've seen
for so many leaders there's a moment in
your personal and professional life
where you realize you're in your own way
yes you're the blocker you know you need
help and that's exactly where belay
comes in but delegating your bookkeeping
to someone can be intimidating and scary
imagine though how your business would
transform if you didn't have to worry
about producing reports and balance
sheets if you had more time energy and
focus to work on things that only you
can do like your product or hiring you
could achieve bigger goals because you
have the freedom to focus on what
matters belay the incredible
organization revolutionizing
productivity with their virtual
assistant service for growing
organizations can help you
that's why they're giving our listeners
a free download of the cost of not doing
your bookkeeping your finances are not
the place to be experimenting holding
your breath fingers crossed and hoping
for the best so if you're ready to wave
the white flag on handling your red and
black margins let one of belay's
experience remote bookkeepers help get
back to doing what only you can do
growing your organization and leave the
bookkeeping to belay just text twist to
55123 or visit belay solutions.com twist
for your free download of the cost of
not doing your bookkeeping today